this no no no no at this point of the
game 6:30 should be fine just let her
know I'll be there let her not be there
I gotta I gotta I gotta talk to a wolf
here I got a I got an appointment with a
wolf a wolf uh where's this war mother a
wolf or what is he war from somewhere my
Mario look at it by the way today's
Mario's birthday can everybody say happy
birthday Mario how are you today Mario
what's more I'll be 33 tomorrow you
gonna be 33 years old how old were you
when you and I first met 18 years old
how old was I when you first met me so
was what 15 years ago is what what do I
have a guest let me give you guys a
surprise with what guests I have on here
let's see fees on can you make the sound
of a wolf what's a wolf sound like if we
got this wolf on here we're waiting on
you I'll send a request to you you just
got accepted do we have the wolf of Wall
Street with us if we do please accept
our request hey yes
how you doing Jordan Belfort what is up
my friend what's the latest what's the
word man how you doing in the state of
California you know I was in Texas the
other day you all right
I was by in Dallas by she just stopped
it and say hello is any other day yeah
I'd apply to need some consulting so I
went down there
nice how was it when you got onto a
flight in the airport where people
little bit weirded out over there pretty
comfortable you know like I mean I'm
honestly over the whole thing listen I
understand that there's a virus but like
you know it's no deadly again the flu
and I just think it's I think if you're
like I spoke to my mom today is 86 I
said mom you know you need to be very
very careful and you need to be you know
sheltering in place though until things
died down but yeah you know I'm not in
the same position is that I have a
really strong immune system and uh you
know I probably already had it plated
you know around all these people for so
long everyone I almost feel sick I
didn't get sick but I had a couple of
days the sniffles maybe you know I don't
don't believe in me I'm not saying it's
not real I just I think it's wildly
overblown the whole thing and it's
fear-mongering and I think it's time to
everyone to get back to work and resume
their lives and these careful as you
want to be if you know everyone makes
their own decision and it's my opinion
you know by the way how was it being
treated in the state of California I'm
in Texas it's like a different house
California treating game you know as
little as I agree with this whole
strategy of social distancing in
lockdowns I have a bit of an abiding by
it because I'm a citizen of the country
and I try to obey the law these days so
I really can't say cuz I haven't put
myself in a position where I've violated
I mean I I don't know what people like
your stories about people yelling at
other people but you know I've been
staying home and you know doing what
we're supposed to be doing is I've been
vocally coming out strongly against the
walk downs and I think like I could I
believe the economic disaster it's
causing is gonna cause many more deaths
than Cove in nineteen
code or Everwood course that being said
you know Marcus is there a mouth not
they're trying to create a revolution
although forgot much further if it goes
much further I would bother exciting
that they're you know really hurting
people at this point think it's become a
political law you know more political
issue than anything else
I don't think Julie about saving lives
anymore it's about politics and covering
your asses and turns out your world a
bit Sweden Sweden is doing just fine
they never lock down and I've been
saying this all along you know and I've
always felt very strongly but you know I
don't again I haven't been going out
there and you know saying screw you to
people so I don't really know if it's
any different
I just know that in Texas it was more
easy to talk to you about yell okay this
is so ridiculous I mean come on what a
joke right and I think most people in
Texas Philly I think California still is
a very liberal state I think a lot of
people here just they're watching MSNBC
and CNN and they're trying to scare the
living [ __ ] out Trump to be thrown out
of office and I think it's a big part of
it it's craziness you know I know you're
well-read guy and you were a science guy
in biology guy
did you ever read the book corporate
flight that came out in 1982 my didn't
but it sounds like the book I would love
what's it about
oh my gosh you're so yesterday I'm
talking to Bobby Kennedy and I did a
three and a three hour interview
together we're sitting out talking about
a bunch of different things and it's
coming out tomorrow morning and he talks
about a book he read called not in 1982
called corporate flight so I'm quite
corporate flight the title I can't
really figure out what their time oh
absolutely to China probably right
corporates like moving outsourced to
China so these guys do a study with the
data to see what the consequences of
each 1% of unemployment going up how
many lives it costs nursery stay there
Jordan for each percent that
unemployment goes up to the million
lights thirty-seven thousand per percent
so think about that if we go to three
percent that's one hundred five thousand
people if we go up six percent that's a
couple hundred thousand people that
means the unemployment is just as
effective of taking lives as the crisis
is I said a million people my guess is a
million PI comes out to a million people
will die that's why I said a million
people because I think that the
employment rate it's 37 thousand 32
pretty 25 percent I mean where is that
employment I was like it's like how many
employees there right now it's crazy
right but they're telling us is
different what we really know the
numbers because the numbers are not
that's enough yeah well I think I think
that you know the way they tap if people
aren't actively searching for jobs then
they don't count it also by the way
saying they created a situation an
unintended consequence is that they made
it actually cost effective to soar to
remain on employed I know people that
have better making more money on
unemployment right now they ever made in
their life working and that's just
insane listen I'm I'm creative of what
Trump is done with with the PPP I
received today I got a very very very
large check today from the government
for the PPA but I'm the perfect guy to
get max I'm gonna take that higher 20
people Jersey
I'm gonna ha I already have all area hi
three people today some expend my cup
day I hired that one person's waiting
for this money to come in fine slow
coming in you know and I was really
upset when I some of the companies that
were taking that money I thought was
really screwed up and I'm really glad
that like a Shake Shack brought it back
and other than but I think a lot of were
embarrassed to bring it back but you
know I was pretty pissed I didn't get
that money up focusing on listen I'm in
the live events business Patrick and
that aspect of my business was decimated
just decimated now I very quickly
pivoted so I focused on my arm but
thankfully I had more than one source
and now I'm reinvesting and I'm growing
me online and just find a whole bunch of
people now at the PBE already today I'm
four people today already got the PP
this morning I four people right and
that like you know at like eight
thousand a month and real real sound so
I'm pretty sure what the government is
done but I I think it could have been
done better I think I think was the they
made the best of a terrible situation I
think could be quicker the money getting
here quick there was a problem as well
you know what do you think about these
guys are bailing out the bigger
companies they're too big to fail
constantly bailing those guys they seem
they should leave him alone or should
they bail him out it's a complicated
question i I think that they set sir
just just saying with a I'm a big
believer in in not bailing people out
okay uh it's but but but that being said
the reason I think that is it has to do
it the the what you do is you create a
situation of you know heads I win tails
you lose with these companies but that
they basically you you create this risk
where like they say let's just grow as
big as we can always bail us out right
so you know there's a very bad paradigm
that you create there so normally like
with the housing bubble I was very much
against bailing out any back I was
absolutely because they made you know
they made their own bed and I thought it
was very very very bad decision you know
the highest and there's other things
involved there but in this case though
you really can't blame the airlines for
what happened in other words this is
this is not immoral you know they call
that a moralizing you know it's a moral
hazard to bail people out because they
made poor management decisions these
companies right now have not then I felt
a moral hazard it's not their fault it
was poor political choice to shut down
the economy so they're really not so I
really have to say miss wanted instance
I would say that large companies that
are getting destroyed like a Boeing or
like that this one or that one it's not
a moral hazard situation they did not do
something that created the situation
that's why it's we're going poor
management let him die okay
fraud let him die but they were
essentially like I'm sorry shutdown
because of a virus that's not their
fault that being said there certainly
should be things in place that ensure
that there should be warrants issued
because these companies gonna become
very profitable again I think the
government could turn this into a
profitable loan not a gift and that I
think is wrong I think some of this
stuff is no strings attached and it
should be strings attached not that
people can't make money or whatever but
they should have to at least give us
warrants as taxpayers we could make
money on the back end like me different
tarp
yeah I'm cute I'm curious to know how
this decision was made to go with the
shutdown you know it was something that
was interesting we said yesterday they
said Kennedy said a found she okay let's
just say he's an expert when it comes on
to virus he's not an expert on the
economy he doesn't know what happens if
you shut down the up on this here's my
very very good guess about what happened
I don't believe in all the conspiracies
about there trying to install 5g ties
this council that is noise I really do I
just don't think it's true and it just
defies you know maybe I'm wrong I don't
think so
okay I don't think that she's a bad guy
I don't think he's trying to control the
world with Bill Gates and put little
microchips in our blood it's the whole
thing is a conspiracy to make us to
accept getting back I don't believe any
of that stuff I really don't what I do
think is that there was some very very
very inaccurate studies they came out of
England from a guy named Neil Ferguson
and uh
lancet from College of Medicine in
London and he made a projection saying
that that in the United States without
any social distancing this was in late
February early March two million people
would die the healthcare system will be
overwhelmed half when people were dying
in Britain and in all this terrible
doomsday projections Trump saw that and
panicked rightfully so I was the
president and I saw a study and everyone
is balanced this is what's gonna happen
unless something changes right now
two million will die because the health
care system will be overwhelmed
you'll be no not mentally detective
equipment and people that people that
could've actually could have actually
lived and survived will die so you have
to shelter in place to slow down the
spread so not to overwhelm the health
care system that was how this started it
was never to try to stop people from
catching cold at 19 it was to stop them
from all catching it at the same time
that was the story but within seven days
of that study coming out Niall Ferguson
himself said oops it's not 2 million I
was wrong it's a hundred thousand people
and then four days at that it's 60
thousand people and half of them would
have died anyway the first year that's
how this started then you had these
Schmucks in Seattle the hm e I ever it
is coming up with these bogus
projections on top of that so Trump
finds himself in this politically
indefensible position if I don't lock
down the country I'm gonna go down as
the president that when everybody died
what was he gonna do he had no choice
but to succumb he tried to find it in
the beginning and then was left in this
position of like if these numbers
there's a 10% chance these numbers are
real I have to stop this from happening
not that we can stop people from
catching the virus but we got to stop
the mole catching it at once
cuz we'll run out of ventilators that
was the whole story but then when it
proved to
be that the virus is not that deadly
it's just not in fact if you take all
the people that have gotten it didn't
know it's like it's 150 at this depth
you take point or one person I said a
month ago it's the flu it kills people
but it's not the worst thing in the
world right it's no deadlier or just
about more or less the same as the flu
give it take 10% either way above a
point one percent number zero point nine
percent point not that deadly so what do
you do you should lock down shelter in
place old people and you can compromise
people and do what Sweden did you let
the normal people go out and catch it
and you end up getting her an immunity
in a couple of months and that's that
you'll destroy the economy and unleash
the power and we spoke about where every
percent unemployed thirty seven thousand
nine in that case we're gonna lose four
hundred thousand lines or more because
of this when we didn't save anybody
others the point was never to stop
people from dying from Kovac nineteen it
was to stop that from all dying at the
same time because then you couldn't save
the ones that could have been saved with
ventilators and health care so once this
all came out the mistake I think Trump
means you should have said you know what
stop this was an error based on bad data
and it's time to just kind of reverse
course but he found himself you know
truck a little bit of Trumpets I kids
want to admit defeat ever liked that
that is a businessman and I think he was
caught in his spot he's got the liberal
media bashing them every single day
making this worse because they want to
trash the economy so Trump doesn't get
elected they don't for what has to
happen to the Liberals the ends justify
the means here if people have to be
unemployed and the cons gotta go to
[ __ ] L to get Trump out of office
we're doing the world a favor and it's
very sick when people what anyone thinks
the ends justifies the means they're
capable of anything
because they believe they have the moral
high ground God is on their side
Morales it doesn't matter what happens
there right so that's why we are where
we are that's my opinion do you agree
with what Allah must said yesterday or
two days ago free America now of course
I do
of course I but I said this I said this
forty days I I was out there I'll tell
you I were out there
the beginning it [ __ ] I took I did a
video and I was really upset one day and
I got a hundred and fifty thousand views
out of it right away and I was like
saying enough you gonna let this stop
you let everyone go back to work you
cannot shut down like a month ago and I
got 90 percent of it was actually hate
mail like you are the biggest P you
don't value human you're a greedy
[ __ ]
and let me just tell you something
catching just has nothing to do with me
maybe I'll always make a living I wasn't
talking about me I'm okay I'm always
gonna make money I'll have good years or
bad years I'm always gonna be okay
alright I was talking about the average
person is gonna be destroyed by this not
me and he was like oh you just wanna
make I don't want to make more money I'm
fine
okay but I know what you're saying
37,000 people died for every 1% how many
of those is type 10 times they don't die
but have terrible anxiety health
problems depression the amount of
maladies that are gonna break up because
of this there's so much negative
consequences because of a lockdown that
the only way it would have made sense is
if 2 million people would have died or
else the cure is gonna be worse than the
medicine that's what happened and now
listen it really remains to be seen at
this point is just how bad do things get
and yeah I don't really I really don't
know that I don't know
you know how things you know there's so
many issues in the supply chain right
now you saw a slight blip of it with
Boyle but you know when you just watch
what happens when it's a lot of supply
chain breaks and all of a sudden this is
excess supply for something and and it's
and the oil goes to negative $30 i watch
that ok happening in shop and then when
I thought it through I realized it was a
function of a solute you already knew it
was gonna happen
two weeks ago because it was a supply
chain Safety happening right now Lou
tell you the next shoe to drop
commercial real estate commercial it is
gonna be off my words mark my words
you're gonna watch the value of
buildings go to what negatives zero be
below
zero the value of buildings is gonna
drop below zero the same way that
gasoline dropped below zero temporarily
watch mark my words that commercial
space goes below zero meaning landlords
will pay people to actually rent out
their spaces toward a percentage of
sales what's just so it's not shuttered
and empty
so other tenants are gonna pay all right
all right why the boys would you want to
walk into a place that has 55% empty
shutting up boarded up places or would
you rather go to a center why do you
think commercial real estate I agree
with you I'm just Kerstin oh you're
arguing wise commercial real estate next
because companies are gonna start
working from home no they're not gonna
go back to going out people have
realized now now I don't love working
from home I don't love the whole thing
but I've realized not for sure that I
can keep 50 or 60% of my staff at home
cheaper just as efficiently and as long
as there's some strong center base I can
do a lot of things from home now my
staff can so take that magnify that
around the world how much office space
out there is never going to get released
because they get multi you dual purpose
Home Office oh so there's gonna be a
massive amount of supply to the point
that it'll be all the flooding now in
addition you have also the u.s. is a
consumer spending based economy as
consumer spending continues to be
crippled by massive unemployment you're
gonna get to the program a lot of these
stores simply are not going to reopen
also because in this time frame
what else are people learned they've
learned that we can buy all our clothes
our food and all our medicine we could
go online we don't need to go to stores
we don't need to do retail shopping out
in malls we can do it from the privacy
of our own home so you get up all these
stores now that are not going to be able
to sustain themselves you're gonna have
empty storefronts and then land was
gonna say wait a second there's so much
empty space it looks so terrible no one
wants to come I'll pay you just to come
in and put your clothing here and give
me a year we'll I'll take eight percent
of sales you just start watching where
wants to get tenants back because they
don't want their places empty the same
things well over supply you can go below
zero people will pay you to occupy their
places just to pay the taxes or
something like that
I believe that's going to happen in the
short in the next three to six months
come on industries that are gonna boom
what do you think I think online
obviously anything that relates to the
world of online delivery
that's why I've completely kid me about
you know to massively into online
education
okay now thankfully I already had done
that thank you I won't say it wasn't
have a stroke of genius it was just dumb
luck by the way that I happened do two
years ago decide to go into that like
adult a very big presence online and I
have my online corporate training
program which is really effective to
sales and and what that's done is it
allowed me to keep it I still lost a lot
of money on this on you know I do a lot
of speaking around the world that's
where a lot of my money comes from so
yes I took a major hit in that but I was
able to offset that and I noticed
there's a warrant big ratcheting up in
my online business almost simultaneous
and and I have not spent a penny and
advertising in months and everyday
people just comment a buy and they buy
and they buy and they buy no advertising
just just all organic people buy every
single day law you know every sit very
very strong and and it's made me realize
that you know that really is you know
for me the future for sure of course I'm
well I can't wait to go back out there
and and and mix with people at live
events and stuff but I do believe it's
going to be quite some time before that
comes back I really do I think that
we're looking more like I would say
you're really looking at 2021 I'm kind
of writing off maybe know maybe uh
September October that might a little
bit but they're talking you know they
don't want until the election is done
the Liberals are going to be destroyed
in any scaring people and let until they
realize that Trump is here to stay and
he's gonna get reelected they're going
to be trying anything possible to stop
the
I'm coming back that's it do anything
they can to undermine an economic
recovery they wanted to be so bad that
will take someone that's senile in place
of Trump that's it and I'm not like I
don't I'm not something like warm
Republican I'm not you know back when I
was younger it was Bill Clinton it was
it was it our George Bush - yeah who
cares you know yeah but it didn't matter
now it's ensiling every guy who can't
remember his own name okay literally
it's like the craziest thing I've ever
seen that this this guy is gonna be the
president and don't toe to toe with
China I mean come on if someone's
getting paid off by China so it's so
don't ISM I've never seen a situation
with such utter corruption in the media
in new york times it's frightening
what what what Facebook does what what
I'm Google they take down things that
they don't believe I cannot believe the
Supreme Court is allowing companies like
Facebook and Google to decide what gets
to be heard and what does not get good I
cannot believe this has not been
challenged yet and it's my fault part of
it cuz I created this whole internet
that you know it's my thing this whole
freedom to speak on the internet was
based on my case in 1991 and to through
it it was I go google it Jordan don't
what created the Internet I was actually
my thing that was a ruling about me that
started the internet in its current form
believe it or not it's up about the
story 1992-1993 back before the internet
was the internet it was just sorry there
was no real internet what you had was a
AOL and CompuServe and these little
message boards and I was the wolf of
Wall Street through Mike Ning and some
guy was trashing me and my company on
message boards online and they were
these chat rooms there was really early
in the game path we're talking 94 93
right right around there you know and
they were singing all the [ __ ] that I
was doing this and that whatever they
were right but didn't matter right so I
sued them my partner I we sued them and
we won I want a massive judgment against
CompuServe which is like the AOL cabal
I won a huge judgment against CompuServe
which was like the agreement of like AOL
and and and Yahoo right now right I won
a US senator was on his plane he was
reading about the story I want and they
went in and a Congress passed a law
called the fair Practices Act which said
that digital platforms are not
responsible for the things that people
say mean you can google see how the wolf
of Wall Street created the Internet it's
actually not as on there's a bunch of
articles about it and they passed the
waters to overturn my lawsuit and I
didn't get to collect on my judgment as
I changed the war and the war was that
Internet platforms are not responsible
for the content that people put on them
fair enough I think it's a good thing
but that's not what's happening now
they're acting now as arbiters of what's
right and wrong under the guise of
removing fraudulent material but the
problem is who's to say what's
fraudulent and what's not or doesn't it
doesn't affect me actually removes is
being fraudulent but I don't like the
fact is Dolly's two doctors out of
California they have this video removed
from Google
I'm very game-like out there do that
like how dare they I can't believe this
I'm shocking Supreme Court was it like
immediately like the happiness be
happening that's like not a solitary
regime Google is I can't believe it
so what to say meaning Jordan let me ask
you a question though say you're running
YouTube I mean I don't know if you saw
the interview that the CEO of YouTube
did with ABC 60 minutes if you haven't
seen it I'll text you I know I saw okay
you know a BC is frightened of YouTube
and YouTube is trying to sit there and
say okay I got to make sure I'm also
doing the right thing what content
should be off and what content should
sale because there's other companies
that try to compete with YouTube in us
they said we have an open platform they
become a porn site within two weeks okay
so let me I am NOT saying that there
should not be it should not be
regulation what I'm saying is there
should be regulation but don't hide
behind this law that was created
according me and say you are not
responsible what's on your
in fact you are Facebook should be
responsible what's on that platform and
so should Google and he should be
regulating like utilities they're not
companies their utilities they're no
different than TV stations and no
different than power companies need to
be heavily heavily heavily heavily
regulated and not companies anymore
they're the actual highways and byways
of information they're the utilities
it's the power source information is
power they regulate power companies they
regulate nuclear power companies do
these people need to be taken over
they're not they're not not they could
stick it all the all of the many of the
operations can be shut off the ancillary
services in the same way they made
Microsoft unbundle Explorer from their
core operations you need to unbundle the
platforms from their other operations
and not happy to have Zuckerberg having
control over the entire social network I
mean how could that be how could this be
allowed to happen
one man is now designing what can be on
and on when it's it can't be no this
needs to be literally this needs to be
government controlled by the government
we can Supreme Court involved is a
really serious thing to me Pat you know
and say I'm the least interfering some
business I don't believe in understand
like I'm saying these are utilities
these are not companies anymore they're
not real public I don't mean the
services they have all these other
services but to regulate what
information is out there that is
dangerous no private company should have
that right but but here's the flip side
of it I'll give it a flip side of it
this is the part that concerns me the
most that what concerns me the most is
for many years
liberals control the media longest time
until they still do well Fox's in some
yes it's not the same as it was before
but until Fox came out and said we're
gonna compete with the Russia so it's
all of social every pretty much a
hundred percent of major social media
companies are controlled by one
political party
why are it why isn't the other side
competing I don't this are liberals more
competitive than Republicans is it are
dem da I don't know it's for its Revenge
of the Nerds
it's
because you're people that the way way
palace structure okay
the way it works basically is that in
the olden days the people who rose up in
power or those who can wield a very
heavy sword people like you pageant okay
you get really well in the old world in
the 1600s and the 700 when you could you
know squeal the sword and fight
hand-to-hand and they pick the club and
bring the woman back to their cave you'd
be great at that Patrick just so happens
you're a smart guy too okay
but for the most part your thumb you're
you're a big strapping man that belongs
in the army if you were in the army
right something like that right there
you go that meant a lot back in that in
between a thousand ad and 2000 ad then
all of a sudden it became that wait a
second the guy who's the biggest guy was
picked last every sports theme the guy
who could never get the girl
all those people now because it's
divisional economy those people that a
complete nerds they expect them I'm I'm
just giving you a very blunt proof they
have become the most richest most
powerful people in the world because
there's no longer they have the police
the US government to protect you against
people the thugs like you pat and they
know that the government of the United
States will protect them against thugs
from coming and raping and pillaging
their village that was how snotty war
and the digital people have taken over
so what's happened is now they get super
super rich and once they are written
they don't want anyone to feel the pain
they felt when they were 12 and they
were rejected and they were picked last
and they didn't get the girl so they
tried to create this artificial playing
field now every because they're already
rich now it's easy to be a liberal when
you're rich really [ __ ] easy
you called it a limousine liberal these
people in LA I mind their [ __ ] gates
okay and saying open up the country
because they're hiding behind a freakin
gates okay let's see how they felt that
the people lived on their property how
they feel about opening up the borders
to illegal immigrants okay so you have
this ridiculous paradigm going on that
or the people in power yeah it's great
moral high ground I'm liberal
rah-rah-rah because Authority rich and
I'm insulated that let's be insulated
and see how liberal they are all right
so that's Mike
what the people that because of the way
what makes money now it's an information
world and the people that are making
money are those that are just we're not
the people it's they wanna rewrite the
rules of what it means to be six they
want you especially pagin you wouldn't
say you believed in bullying on my
podcast these were the kids that were
bullied all right they were bullied
these kids and I don't disagree with
that I didn't agree with that we have to
agree in everything right but the point
was is that utter which you had an
experience with your daughter of 1415 I
remember you were making the point that
was well a well received I understood
your point you were making you don't
believe me she's bullying to the toy
someone's like gonna commit suicide
people need to deal with the realities
of the world they're trying to create a
world right now where there is no
reality in the real world it's everyone
gets a trophy that's not true everyone
doesn't get a trophy if everyone gets a
trophy that you should not have more
money because more money is the trophy
of adults right and you should get that
all your money and spread it all around
no one should win the game you're all
communist a socialist basically so this
is wild socialist you know ideal and
also it was also from McCarthyism as bad
as it was in some respects he didn't
fully do his job and while they remain
they eliminated a lot of socialists and
communists they didn't get the ones in
the educational institutions and the
socialists instantly infiltrated the
educational institutions of America and
they literally of brainwashed our
children from going on for 30 and 40
years and they won they won so now we're
sitting saying wait a second I'm this
happened that's how it happened they won
they infiltrated a this Alinsky pack
movement I've done all these things and
now Trump was the last that was the
common person the way comes and wait a
second this doesn't feel right this
doesn't seem right this is not the
country I grew up in what happened to my
civil rights
what happened to freedom of speech what
why do I agree with the transgender
person and just you know I'm the most
socially liberal guy on the planet I
don't care who suits you the who who
uses what death I don't give a [ __ ]
about anything but don't legislate to me
what I have to accept or not accept so I
think a lot of people we
look at his ultra-liberal [ __ ] [ __ ]
Hollywood scum that on the most
self-righteous pigs in the world
self-righteous [ __ ] pigs that bet
it's everything they say they do the
opposite there's such liars
okay so self-righteous on everything
with global warming and they're just a
big everything it's disgusting and
people knew that intuitively in their
hearts they felt something wrong and
they voted for Trump and I'm not I don't
love a lot of things Trump says us but
no he's a freaking warrior and the fact
that my president said how the hell is
the post office losing all this money
and charging amazon one-fourth of what
they should reach what the [ __ ] am i
substantive Jeff Bezos paycheck
what the hell was that about when I
heard that not maybe he was not maybe
Trump was not saying the truth but if
it's true that they're charging Amazon
one for what they're losing 400 percent
every package they ship the Amazon I am
really pissed about that I'm outraged
because Amazon didn't pay taxes they
economists be allowed to happen what is
going on
so like the country that I grew up in is
not been destroyed basically it's been
destroyed from the inside out through
corrupt Congress people a corrupt
government corruption and government no
term limits there's so much wrong there
is so much wrong and even the Liberals
are really bad at the term of the thing
no term limits are just utterly
disastrous professional politicians
should not be allowed to even exist
lobbyists should be thrown out I mean
there's so much wrong Patrick that it's
really sad because you know I'm always
gonna do okay and so will you that's not
who's gonna suffer you and I will do
fine it's the average man and woman the
average person here that suffers that
barely escapes by and watch is how these
know these ultra corporate Titans that
he steals robbed them it's not it's not
if there's a lot of thievery going on
right now it's a pillaging raping
littering on village the things that
we're allowed to happen
in the outsourcing jobs they'll advise
you to outsource to China it's crazy
it's crazy so so in other words what
you're saying is we got to start a new
website called Republican nerds calm and
start recruiting some Republican nerds
there are Piatt deals one if you lose
one no doubt about it I'm sorry but I
think that muskies another must is
another but people are socially all
socially liberal like me I'm social the
most socially liberal person you would
meet I don't care about anything have
you doing what the person is their body
what they believe I don't care about
that I don't know why I have no right to
okay everyone deserves to be happy and
to be able to express who they are okay
and everyone has the right to be able to
condemn them if they watch it like
that's just the way it is okay and I
just don't think it's government's right
to step in and that's where I depart
from the Liberals but I agree with the
philosophy that everyone deserves
happiness and the right to pursue it
every day wanna marry who you want sleep
with who you want dress the one who
cares I don't care so but again going
back to it man you know that's the one
part if there's a messaging that I would
give us the following here here's a
message of not God when guys come up to
me and they say well you know it's not
fair and those guys are doing this and
these guys are doing this um those guys
are doing this I said go compete with
them why don't you go compete with them
here's what I mean by that you got a
Peter Thiel Peter Thiel's not a
lightweight and he's not afraid of
anybody he's a pretty vocal guy and
there's a lot of guys out there why
aren't they coming together and deciding
to compete and putting like take the top
ten industries whether it's a a PayPal
model whether it's a eBay model whether
it's a social media model but it's a
YouTube model it's an Amazon model have
them start working together creating a
joint venture put the funds together
raise the money start these platforms
start / stop promoting them competing
because the long term it's not a one you
play to either play ten years from now
if they decide to shut somebody down on
one market they can over here because
we're running on different guidelines
the best thing that could ever happen to
this world is a replacement for Facebook
and Instagram Google is not a monopoly
they're just not okay so I am
as much as I don't agree with what
Google did and you two did they're not a
monopoly they're not okay they have a
huge market share and I believe it
should be I believe they should be
utilities
I still believe what I said but Facebook
is monopoly it is an absolute monopoly
all right and there's an evil evil evil
monopoly right now that needs to be
taken apart okay it's one thing if you
could separate Facebook and Instagram
that would be enough by the way that
would be enough to resolve some of the
problem but you cannot have Facebook and
Instagram as the same company it is
disgusting
disgusting I cannot believe it's been
allowed to happen then the amount of
tell you offset it going on I can't even
imagine how this has been allowed to
happen they've destroyed like what a
destroyed freedom that one company can
now dictate any online success of
failure allowing how could that be
allowed I don't get it and I think
you're right Pat I think the best thing
in the world that can happen would be
for there to be a platform that I would
literally jump on it so quickly and I
would literally jump off I mean here's
the thing I don't want so I use Facebook
right now I don't
okay I use it for my messaging and stuff
and I have a big audience my life would
go on without Facebook or Instagram
it really would if we go on with that
it's a great way for me to communicate
with my fan base and I use it but I
would literally if there was an
alternative I would hightail it off of
there so fast you were not even
believing believe I mean like I think
you would too right I think so many
people would everyone knows it's not
right what's happening it's just not
right it's not right shouldn't be
allowed JB what's the first news you
read in the morning when you wake up
what sources do you go to fox i got a
fox news in the new york I go to Fox
News New York Times CNN MSNBC I don't of
for and then I go online and it'll go on
Facebook and me all the lies on Facebook
and then I guess only I laugh and I
check back and I look like face you can
see how much nonsense is on Facebook
it's 90
percent lies on Facebook not and the way
they do it is such a joke is that their
algorithms only show you what you want
to see so they could put you an echo
chamber their algorithm says oh he likes
this stuff so we'll just show more and
more what he likes and you didn't
getting a skewed there after the fire
obviously I wasn't defined destroy the
country Facebook it's the most evil
place I've ever seen it's so evil I
really believe that I
I think it's evil I don't know if he
meant it to be but he's obviously really
there's something unwell about the whole
way that operates like everything from
having algorithms that that only show
you what you want to see so all you do
is hear people who that it creates all
it does it creates massive polarization
that's why that's why we're so spread
apart right now I think we spoke about
that study given that were a professor
created two profiles and then one sort
of commenting only liberal comments
conservative and within 30 days it was
like we were looking at a different news
that the world was your one person saw
one senators the other that's the
healthy that's not healthy at all so a
committee I think you know I don't think
things like a bird is a bad guy really
don't I know it's beyond this big it's
like you know he's one guy at this place
it's like this gigantic machine and he
can't possibly up on everything that's
going on but there's a lot of terrible
terrible people that together I'm
creating a culture there that's just
awful they have too much power they
really have way too much power for
anyone to have and it's not to be a
government it's gotta be a government
it's gotta be a utility it's gotta be
utility it's the money we're talking
about gauge your concern isn't as much
gauge you're more concerned about suck
than you are my Gates Bill Gates is a
really well-intentioned I don't agree
with him at all I don't agree with Bill
Gates I think he's a really
well-intentioned guy I don't think he's
got any even my opinion I think he's a
really good person that really gives
back really wants to give back and
really wants to help the world I just
don't agree with the way he's going in
some respects I don't agree with
everything he thinks but I don't think
he's a bad person at all
at all is why just my opinion just my
opinion that's fine that's why I'm
asking
there's not a right or wrong I'm just
curious about the information right now
who would you say right now is the most
powerful people in the world in your
opinion who the most powerful people in
on the laurels of the Burgundy's us Wow
Zuckerberg more than anybody by far you
put suck 1 and based on what premise
which data
how are you strolls so he controls
basically most money advertising is
spent which controls all the eggs all
right all the abilities what can what
can be advertised what can not be he can
tip elections like what by what he
allows that this guy can control every
election everywhere around the world
except in China because it's facebook's
not dominant there but anyway they're
good by gaming news feeds he can what
you see what you don't see it's so
simple for him to control everything
who was your friend you could
communicate with what you see in your
newsfeed who can advertise on my
platform who can what's considered trees
what's hate what's not what user Excel
is though how can one man be allowed to
decide that how could one upper you be
allowed to decide that it's like aliens
everything it's his fault
I think this is an impossible position
the guy and those I don't like again
when Gates was doing what Gates is doing
I probably said always a twist cuz he's
driving other companies he was just
being the ultimate capitalist gates
right now he was a bad guy
I don't think Zuckerberg has any bad
intentions wasn't was he's not a
terrible person I just think that he's
it is an impossible position for a man
to be it he's tried to run a company and
make money that's what a company is
designed to do but it's gone to a point
where it's become a utility it's no
longer a company Facebook this is a way
that people are it's like the
information Highway who owns the
highways in the United States no one the
public owns the highways the happy it
must be owned by the public
it can't be owned by a man how people
could communicate the same goes in
Google and I think Google I think Google
is Google in that third thing people at
Google are equally as I think though
that they have less maybe I'm
okay but to me there's a bit less power
they have in Google like like with
Zuckerberg you know like big YouTube is
one thing right YouTube is one thing but
I really doing social meeting is
something like so big that and I think
it gets bigger and bigger every single
check that 10 years from now all the
kids they're only gonna use that to
communicate and find news out and I
really I think it's such a dangerous
dangerous thing that's happening right
now and I can't believe it's been
allowed to happen I don't understand
most you know almost almost I've almost
given up I've really almost given up
because at this point in my life you
know I also look out for my own
interests and I'm out there I'm living
my life and like what's I mean how many
good years ago thirty years left on this
planet for 40 years maybe what am I
gonna do I'm gonna try to take down the
Institute you know I feel I'm really
really upset didn't happen I'm vocal
about it
but I'm not gonna sit there and start
blowing up everything look what are you
supposed to do I mean and and you know
and I come with the added deficit of
people will attack my past if I come out
I know that all right so I gotta own
even or else like PI or else I can be on
every single TV station right now but
because of the wolf of Wall Street has
this double edged sword and I get I get
knocked down too quickly by competing if
I come out with you know and snow what's
going on alright so and my friends but
that doesn't affect my business per se
is my fans know better but it's just
like stops me from being able to get and
see some level I can't penetrate at the
top yes all right
and I'm also you know I'm getting sick
and tired of the government just doing
nothing I'm watching them lie and lie
and just lie and I see things like what
this thing about about all about what
happened with twin general Flynn and I'm
disgusted how could he not be in jail
the FBI
I got went to jail to lie to the FBI
have to make it not have to make in line
like I don't get it it's like I'm living
in the matrix almost like it's not is
there something wrong yeah like the
rules are real
good and bad right and wrong justice and
injustice they no longer really apply
what do you think I'm just saying you
got to keep your eyes open today for me
a friend of mine called me yesterday
from high school that's the kid out most
in sixteen years always to work out when
I was bench pressing barely 45 pounds to
bar you know when we were skinnier like
toothpicks and he calls me says I've not
been watching TV lately I said okay what
have you been watching he says I've just
been watching by a tainment I said okay
uh-uh what's going on he says uh are you
not concerned about the people you're
interviewing I said what do you mean he
said that some of the topics you're
touching on may not be the best topic to
be touching on because it's bringing a
lot of attention you know people are
concerned are you not concerned yourself
I said you know I take a couple
different things here for me number one
I've always since I was a kid I've
questioned everything I'm not the guide
a naive guy that wants to jump to
conclusion both sides always my mother's
side there were communists my dad sides
were imperialists like let me hear both
of these guys argument why do you think
rich people are bad tell me I want five
reasons why they're bad why do you think
poor people are lazy so I think for me
it's more about watching it very closely
and educating yourself and seeing
answers and then at the same time I got
a guy that called me very interesting
guy you know who this guy's I'm just not
gonna mention it for his own protection
he calls me says hey yeah I'm in I'm in
Hollywood and this is a very good friend
and he's very very well known he's he's
done it good for himself he's been as
one of the best in his industry and he
says oh man I'm trying to do this thing
in Hollywood I'm trying to get some
opportunities here but you know I'm a
I'm a supporter of what's going on with
the economy and what this person that
I'm what that person good and one of my
friends call me the other day with
politics and Trump and all this other
stuff what do I do
I said do you have ten million in the
bank he said no I said you don't have
money in the bank he said no I saying
you want to get into Hollywood I do I
said I wouldn't talk until I had ten
million on the Mac he says series that
said what advice for me to give you if
you don't have money you will be kicked
out of the industry especially in that
industry ago
- you can't just sit there and say oh
I'm uh you know uh I got a message I'm
gonna go out there and do this fine but
just so you know if you go that route
you're gonna be in that route for a long
time the biggest thing I'm telling
people nowadays is if you want to be
able to help will have a loud voice and
not be afraid of what people gonna be
saying to you make sure you protect your
money quickly go get your money in place
and lock yourself up then at that's at
that time if you feel a need to want to
make an opinion and kind of share some
of your belief system do so yesterday
I've always been enamored by the Kennedy
family always I've always been curious
about this Joseph Kennedy set guy I've
always been you know I'm a serious seven
guy you and I industry you were doing
what you were doing I was with Morgan
but I've always been curious about
Joseph Kennedy John F Kennedy how this
family was raised so yesterday I'm
talking to this guy and I say to Bobby
and I say hey you got a strong position
with vaccine I said but let me tell you
what your family said they would an open
letter to you he says really I said yeah
this is why I know that open letter so I
read the open letter to him it says RFK
we love you but we disagree with you
tremendously so I said what do you think
about your family disagreeing with you
his answer was powerful what he says JB
paola he says Patrick you have to
realize the Kennedy family has 105 kids
he says when I was a kid a baby and I
would come home my parents had a rule
every night during dinner my mom and dad
would ask us questions and it would
force us to debate each other to the
point of arguing I said elaborate he
said my dad would say do you think LSD
is good for you
do you think every kid should test LSD
what do you think about fascism in Italy
what do you see my communism what do you
think about rich people you think rich
people should give their money back and
they would bring up a topic and
everybody would debate debate that they
debate debate and this guy ends up being
an environmental lawyer and obviously
goes up and do this what he does with
climate change whether you agree with
him or not but the point is some
families want to push the envelope and
if you want to be somebody that's you
know going and playing it low-key and
safe it's
not a good idea to make a lot of noise
there's two places to be low-key one get
a regular job just go make a living get
a nice apartment don't make a lot of
noise follow all the rules whatever the
media tells you whatever the news tells
you whatever everybody tells you make 60
70 80 grand you're a little safe life
that's okay you can do that or go make
your money make your tens of millions go
away from everybody
live your nice luxurious life and don't
make a lot of noise
then there's the crazies the crazies
can't stay quiet and I think sometimes
the world uses weird people to make some
noise and I know you said earlier you
said every time you come up and say
something people use your pass and they
say well you know what about you and
underpass on what you did sometimes a
guy like you needs to be more vocal
because you can go and talk about
experiences that you've had I love that
cuz I was like that with my feel about
the banging things and I think it's good
that there's different points of view I
think the problem is right now is that
the day of arguing based on logic is
over all the Liberals will do is it all
becomes emotion they just label you as
being racist not caring about human life
not caring about the aplan perceived
moral high-ground
that trumps everything doesn't matter
what you say anymore tell me all
liberals but I watch TV and I'm just
saying I and the reason I watch it is
that wanna stay in form I won't just
watch Fox News or oh way and do it
because I then I'm gonna get in an echo
chamber myself I want to see what they
say and some of the [ __ ] that they say
is just so shocking and obviously not
true and obviously self-serving I will
say this about handling he story is the
first one to admit he goes I am NOT a
journalist I am an opinion shown like
this is a you know he says like it is my
opinion it's not fat it's my opinion and
then he tries to read in his fact the
point is he at least he says it's not
but what's happening right now on CNN
they're actually
there are news agency they're not a news
agency at all
it's like 24-hour opinionated and that's
okay but they should say the best
opinions that fit the print like don't
say it's news anymore it's not news what
they have it's a joke it's a total joke
and what that does and the sad thing is
is that it forces Trump to act like an
[ __ ] sometimes because he asked him
because he's almost like if someone
pushes your back to the wall that
intensely every single day then you and
you end up having today I'm not saying
he's a perfect I'm saying he's not okay
but I can only imagine what I'd be like
if I was being attacked every second of
every single babe and I know what I did
and be more just lying about me accusing
me it's just like crazy crazy like
they're saying that this is his fault
coronavirus I watched Nancy Pelosi like
she's being shown a clip of her in
Chinatown come to Chinatown it's a safe
oh stop the current and after Trump
noted sadly travel ban and she said it
was it was racist the travel ban and now
she's saying well Trump did max in love
and they showed her the clip because I
go no ya know and she just did as if
like I'm like wait but but Nancy I saw
him we all saw it like we know you're
lying full of [ __ ]
what are you talking about like you're
just lying through the camera and no one
calls around on it like no one just says
Nancy plus you're a liar you can't you
know I'm not saying Trump couldn't have
done more but you can't say that was you
well even worse and by the way I'm not
even saying that you were wrong by the
way how about this based on the
information you had at that moment you
believed I'm sure I might I'm sure you
were not trying to hurt people by having
him come to Chinatown I believe your
intentions were pure yes come to
Chinatown it's safe don't worry about it
right but you were wrong Trump was you
didn't have the ambition the don't try
to rewrite history and say you were
ahead of Trump in it's not safe thing
that's what bothers me
not that she did something wrong by
going to Chinatown there was nothing
wrong with that she was doing with any
problems that she would do but the don't
try to just lied about it
it's crazy it's like you're living in in
alternative universe I but do you think
any of these things are new like meaning
all this manipulation you think it's no
it's been going on forever it's much
more intense Matt because everything is
recorded so you get caught oh that's
great what's happening is though is that
what's happening is that you're now able
to see no one gets away with anything
everything is out there every little
thing is analyzed its own post something
for a split second and it takes it down
oops too late so let me ask you this
though who's getting pushed and bullied
more our Democrats bully and Republicans
or Republicans bullion Democrats more
Democrats a believer but you know what
that means that they're the biggest
[ __ ] in the world on public but you
know what and I'm a Republican we all
the work absolutely shocking I always
say well I guess the Republicans know
the end they they got the guns so it
really comes down to when they get a win
but they I don't think that's really
right because you know I don't have a
gun but I just I really am shocked the
way the Republicans allow themselves to
get pushed around by that it's a crawl
most insane insane myself if you look at
anybody that is in UFC almost anybody
that's a UFC and you ask them why did
you become a fighter they will typically
tell you what happened I didn't wanna be
pushed around anymore
somebody bullied me and I don't want to
push on them so to the strength to me is
on the opposite side of the Democrats I
don't think they're making themselves
tougher because when every single news
station favors you you don't become
stronger you don't have to debate
everywhere you go they agree with you I
think there's an underground of leaders
being developed that we haven't seen yet
I think the next five to ten years the
the movement is gonna be so amazing of
leaders being a rising up that's gonna
people gonna realize maybe we pushed a
little too hard that's what I foresee
taking what I mean meet me on the
connect more conservative libertarian
voices will rise out you you cannot
bully people like this for too long you
can't do that people are not gonna take
it for too long but there are most
people are like that like words like a
Candace Owens would you say
you're gonna see that times a thousand
like not just one you're gonna see a
thousand of them you're gonna see ten
thousand of them you can't bully a
community for too long I sincerely hope
you're right Patrick because I will tell
you because I'm literally at my wit's
end I feel like almost like the less you
know because like you know I I am very
vocal about like I'll complain right now
you just have shooting the [ __ ] I'm very
vocal about my views and I think a lot
of [ __ ] for it online I don't really
care about that because I it's like my
business and my mom one's really mesh
much I can say what I want you know
people I'm lucky I have a great I have a
program that's really works well my
sales for yourself people by teasing
they hate me because it works right but
the point is is that I I really hope
you're right I think the one danger here
the one danger is that at a certain
point at a certain point if the people
that control the infrastructure meaning
the pipes the information highway if it
gets back the way it is right now it's
so skewed to the liberal side of the
equation that if it bet you're right in
its test for you're right on one side
you're right it's forcing us to get
tougher and tougher but this shutting
content yet removing free speech it's
alright
let me tell you why I think it's alright
Jordan I'm telling you this I'm telling
you this from a former from a
perspective of knowing the following say
somebody's evil say in the empire's is
say policies evil say any of these
people are even let's just play that
card say they're evil right she's
already there or she's here waiting for
me it's all right it's just tell them
five minutes
I gotta go five minutes their self yeah
so that's good so let's just say they're
evil let's say hypothetically they're
evil how long if they're evil to the
opposition don't you think they're evil
period or to the people that they work
with on the daily basis to their
supporting cast
if you eventually stay like that and you
like that to everybody you eventually
become like that to your family and to
the people around you and when you do
that to your own camp the worst kind of
opposition you turn is those
- were one supporters of you and they
become the biggest enemies of you that's
exactly what's gonna happen
you cannot bully people for too long no
way in the world I'm a guy that grew up
in Iran and I lived in Iran for ten
years we were constantly being bully and
people would say a lot of different
things you know well you know here's
what's gonna happen and I'm a guy that
grew up in a family where my dad who
helped a lot of guys will meet when my
parents got a divorce I went to a
Christmas party one time and my family
the family that we were at those are the
ones that would be up you know uppity
and high mighty and their doctors and
I'm 25 26 years old at that time I'm
barely making six figures I'm not doing
anything crazy with my life and my dad's
working at a 99-cent store so we're not
like everybody looks at us like oh you
know the poor bit David family you know
Jordan the looks they gave me I remember
it till today and I said he will never
bully my dad you can bully me I'm
tolerant I'm okay with that you crossed
my dad you have a permanent enemy for
life
the more they bully the bigger and
stronger the opposition is gonna be so
let me just tell you the more and more
you're talking believe me just as much
as you got 80% you guys that may be
getting pissed off at you there's 20% of
them that are underground that just
don't want to say anything because
they're non-controversial let me pass
let me ask you by the way just you know
in the last made a series of four posts
on Kovan it went from 90% hating me to
90% loving me neither games but also one
more point on why is is someone working
on it'll turn the platform right now
today yes yes yes I know it needs to
happen yes and and yes we can talk
offline but the answer is yes absolutely
I want to talk about that it's a very
pal I will go on the world I will
literally donate every penny I make when
I retire in a few more years and I will
literally support that platform every by
last dying breath to write what's gone
on what is happen do this for too long
make no can't bully people for too long
you're gonna be pissed them off yeah and
then they're permanent enemies anyways
brother last question for before we wrap
up when's the last time you watch wolf
of Wall Street
six months ago with my girlfriend
washing six months ago so I'm telling
you every time I watch that movie I
think about my first time I took my dad
and we watch it at the LA at the theater
my dad's like I'm gonna go watch this
war for Wall Street I said you want to
watch war for Wall Street
he said Patrick it's a crazy story we
have to go watch it I like it like an 85
year old grandma let's talk soon buddy
everybody take care man bye bye bye